at this altitude I can run flat-out for
my hands this episode's brought to you
by peloton and I'd heard about peloton
over and over again but I ended up
getting a peloton bike in the whole
system after I saw my buddy Kevin Rose
I've known him forever
some of you know and he showed up at my
gate at my house a while back and he
looked fantastic hey I asked was a dude
you look great what the hell have you
been up to because he's always doing a
weird diet or another but it only lasts
like a week or two so he always
regresses to the mean after like 75
beers and he said I've been doing
peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention because
Kevin does nothing five days a week and
you know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home you don't have to worry about
fitting classes in your schedule or
making it to a studio with some type of
commute etc new classes are added every
day and this includes options led by
elite New York City instructors in your
own living room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you but we usually just use
classes on demand I really like Matt
Wilbur's and design high intensity
training sessions that are shorter like
20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite
is Alex and everyone seems to have their
favorite instructor or you can select by
music duration and so on each peloton
bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking
Trix I think that along with the
real-time leaderboard are the main
reasons that this caught my attention
when cycling never had caught my
attention before it's really pretty
stunning what they've done with the user
interface to keep your attention the
belt drive is quiet and it's smaller
than you would expect so it can fit in a
living room or in office I actually have
it in a large closet believe it or not
and it fits with no problem so peloton
is offering all of you guys listeners of
the Tim Ferriss show a special offer and
it is actually special visit one peloton
that's Oh n e PE l OT o n 1 peloton calm
and enter the code Tim all caps TI m at
checkout to receive $100 off accessories
with your peloton bike purchase now you
might say mat accessories wait I don't
need fancy towels or whatever other
supplemental bits and pieces no the
shoes you need you need the clip in
shoes and those are in the accessory
category so this $100 off is a very
legit so if you want to get in your
workouts if you want a convenient and
really entertaining way to do
high-intensity interval training or
anything else or you just want to get a
fantastic gift for someone
check out peloton one pallet on.com and
enter the code Tim again that's Oh any
PE l o t-- o-- n dot-com and enter the
code Tim a check out to receive $100 off
any accessories including the shoes that
you will want to get check it out one
peloton comm code Tim
this episode is sponsored by Sotheby's
and South appease wine which offers a
selection of the world's best wines for
every palate and occasion many of you
know I do like my wine
I do love wine must be the Malbec from
Argentina when I was down there or maybe
it's the Zinfandel from California but I
like it all I like lots and lots of wine
Sotheby's as many of you may know is a
global auctioneer they auction off many
many many different types of things
they're also a retailer of fine wine
with locations in New York London and
Hong Kong they recently created an
online store where you can buy wine
directly you might think well that's for
millionaires and billionaires I don't go
to auction houses but the wines that
they sell range from $14 per bottle all
the way up to 25,000 let's say South
Obie's allows you to sort by region
great producer or you can search for a
particular bottle or by your budget
which is probably where I would go if
you're gifting wine South Bay's suggest
champagne red Bordeaux burgundy or
Californian wines and if you want my
opinion I would say you know try and
symfon del if you haven't tried to
Zinfandel from California but in any
case just one restriction at this time
South Obi's can only ship to New York
California DC New Hampshire and Idaho so
I'll say that one more time I'll put it
a different way if you are in or
shipping to New York California DC New
Hampshire or Idaho check it out because
that's where the wine can currently be
shipped so visit Sotheby's wine.com thus
s th e b ys Safa b's wine.com and use
the promo code Tim T I am to get 10% off
of your first order again that's south
appease wine.com
and use promo code Tim for 10% off of
y'all delicious wine check it out
why hello there and welcome to another
episode of the Tim varys show this is
Tim Ferriss and it is typically my job
to share the habits and routines of
world-class performers of all different
types as well as try to spot the
patterns amongst them and talk about
that this episode is a rare exception to
the rule and unlike my usual long-form
interviews this is a drunk-dialing Q&A
with you guys my listeners so what does
that mean I've done this a few times in
the past including for the celebration
of the hundredth episode of this podcast
we're at more than 300 now so it's been
a while and here's how it works
in preparation for this episode I went
on the social media and point people to
a Google forum or they could input their
phone numbers and so on and those people
our listeners want to receive a call
from me then I said hey from this time
to this time I'm gonna be making phone
calls and I started drinking and dialing
answering your questions and getting a
little frisky along the way tequila will
do that and we covered a lot in this
episode I cover all sorts of things
including how jaakko will Inc has made
me more disciplined my thoughts on sex
as a doorway to higher perception that
was not a topic I expected to get into
and you name it we cover it I talk about
past addiction to stimulants that I've
had and how I have weaned myself off of
said stimulants or least prioritized
abstinence from stimulants how I
determine if a project is working or not
put another way how do I decide when I
should persevere or quit a project stop
something and move on and after all the
fastest way to complete something is to
leave it undone forever
so that's one topic that we dig into how
I think about teaching and much much
more so I'll leave it at that without
further ado please enjoy this tequila
fuelled Q&A with you guys and thanks for
being game here we go
hello hi is this Brennan it is Tim
Farriss good evening why oh man where am
I where am i finding I'm doing great
where are you right now I'm actually
probably about three hours north of I'm
in Dallas Texas
oh nice it's fine town to find town
Dallas I've been here I've been here
I've been there that's the alcohol
talking excuse me I have been there a
handful of times as well as Fort Worth
but I've always spent more time in the
Austin area
so yeah understandably so it's it's it's
a fine fine community I was just
actually down there yesterday very nice
for South by or what were you down here
for him no I just went down to go to the
an Academy and to get a little workout
in and synchronize to synchronistically
enough you really set podcast with
Aubrey this yesterday it's a great it's
a great gym so I tell you what I've got
a bunch of phone calls to make a bunch
of booze to drink so how can i how can I
attempt to help what type of questions
might I take a stab at good good
question because I know you collect them
so I actually took a little bit of time
once I saw that tweet I was expecting
this phone call so an easy one that I
just wanted to ask because it's been one
of the biggest things that you saw me
with of all the people that you've
introduced in the keys the Holy of works
is juggle willing so I wanted to know
just from your perspective as having him
around in your life made you more
disciplined that is a fine question yes
so having Jocko around in my life which
I will say is also virtual even though I
know Jocko very well I just I just spoke
to him yesterday on the phone but simply
knowing that Jocko exists in the
universe makes me feel like I have a
very benevolent yet strict guardian
angel who will most certainly give me an
occasional pat on the back
but more often a kick in the ass to
actually do it what needs being done so
Jocko I think exemplifies for me at
least the importance of deciding to
embody a given attribute as a means to
developing that attribute so of course
Jocko is well known for saying if you
want to be tougher be tougher simply
meeting in that context that if you want
to be tougher it's not a six-month plan
it's not a two-year plan it's not a
progression it is do I choose the stairs
instead of the elevator when I get up
from this table and I need to go to
another floor and it can be a small
decision it can be a big decision but
you want to immediately start making
decisions that reflect the
characteristic you want to develop and
that that I think is very powerful and
also quite frankly the simplicity of
Jacko's approach to many things
including physical fitness and training
which some of these like even the
beginner were there so simply put
together about like you know difficult
to execute with correct form and like
advocating the proper cadence and you
know everything like that like right I
think that is his principle simple from
extreme ownership you know it's like
just don't over complicate things and I
think that in a way simplicity is like
you know expression of elegance it is
absolutely and also the fact that Jaco
does not accept excuses in his own life
and certainly doesn't accept them from
other people and as one example he if
he's traveling and you know this from
having read the last book but if he's
travelling and he wants to do pull-ups
and he doesn't have any pull-up bar
nearby let's say in a hotel
he will take a towel go to the parking
garage find something from which he can
hang effectively using the towel like
throw it over a bar or something like
that and holdups exactly right so in
those for those of you who don't have
the contacts jockle will Inc is a
legendary former or I should say retired
Navy SEAL commander he was
charge at one point of all West Coast
training for Navy SEAL Teams which are
certainly realistic hyper-realistic one
might even call psychotic he's a black
belt in Brazilian jiu-jitsu and can do
last I heard 67 strict pull-ups at a
body weight of somewhere between 2:15
and 2:30 so the guy is absolutely animal
and then like just a mental monster -
you know I like the way he approaches
life is just so like it's it's a
different kind of like inspiration and
motivation it's like a really like salt
examina Tori like a look at yourself and
like just be realistic about how many
hours you're willing to put in the day
you know like a lot of people if they
you know they could be night owls and
they might stay up till 4:30 or you know
so long as you're putting in work
between like midnight and like 6:00 a.m.
at some point you're still ahead of most
people or most of it that's before you
go to sleep or if you like when you get
up yep
so if you want to also see the most
hilarious Twitter Q&A is imaginable you
can follow John Jaco wailing on Twitter
okay enough enough Jocko I love Jocko
but I just want to wrap up with one
thing you remember
oh you know what I should say I
apologize just to interrupt I'll say if
people want to get to know Jocko the
very first interview he ever did
publicly was on my podcast you can just
go to Tim da blog forward slash Jocko
and yeah you thought you said a monster
loose like thing like the video he came
over there just a day or two days ago
it's about the clock running out like
people should check out his youtube
channel cuz it's this way two two and a
half minutes or something it's amazing
yep so I've helped to create or rather
just really unleash on the Internet in a
monster no jaco willing so enjoy okay so
what's next
I'm drinking Casa Dragones sipping
tequila in this case 100% pure agave
azul made and it's from san miguel de
allende and it is tequila Blanco
it's nice stuff totally
what alley or alley what cool so the
last question is I like I see we met did
you you know that do you remember that
it was I campus LA you did your you did
like a like like basically like a meet
McCleary oh I remember cross campus mmm
yeah so I flew up from Dallas actually
that time and got to kind of interact
with you a little bit it was pretty cool
I think I met you in this hallway space
it was by the way in the back of the
room behind the main stage kind of on my
way to get a drink and go to the
bathroom I think I actually he kind of
stepped in front of a few people and I
met you there if I remember correctly
people like like I remember the very
beginning you were like yeah please like
I'm not taking startup you know pictures
right now it was just like it soon as it
was a break for coffee like you have to
go for the coffee and it was just like
swarmed with people asking about like Oh
would you take this product that like
this guy from Soylent was there and like
it's like all these people and they were
just swarming you and I got a second to
talk to you and I was just like I just
want to say thank you and I hope you
want to say thank you today man I'm
really grateful for everything you've
really led me towards in my life like I
basically you're like one of the best
decision making or content filtering
algorithms that I've ever found because
if you vet something it's already like
so much of the leg work is done and I
just trust you on like you know you're
driven for research and helping people
so thank you Brandon yeah I hope hope to
never betray that trust
I mean I do I'd really work hard to not
succumb to the temptation to loosen that
filter it's it's very it can be very
challenging it's very expensive but yeah
I I know how valuable that is to me I
have friends who act as filters
certainly and it's it's it's largely
thanks to the value that I've derived
from them that I want to try to serve
the same function for people in the
wider world that I can hopefully try a
thousand things and a lot of [ __ ]
and distill the two or three that are
actually worth yeah a second look well
thank you so much for calling like I
don't know I want to be respectful
everybody else do you know like I could
talk to you forever like you think huge
inspirations just thank you so much my
pleasure man any any requests for the
podcast types of people specific people
or anything introduced to your work in
2011 I was basically I grew up in
hospitality and other chef from any of
the last years and was just unable to
kind of sustain like a healthy lifestyle
and like work like you know there was no
such thing as work/life balance if
you're like a cheese chef cooking real
food like in a high-pressure fine-dining
environment like what everything's made
from scratch it's just I know you know
that from your research and you know
going through with the 4-hour chef but
like it's a pretty wide spread like
unknown issue in the States right now
that there's not enough skilled labor in
kitchens not just kitchens restaurants
in general so I don't know I mean like I
want to make a difference in that
industry on like a bigger scale
so I mean I want to put together like a
website and like I have like a ton of
ideas in the realm of trying to help
people in that specific genre of well I
should say niche of like the workplace
but because I have so much experience
like I grew up in a restaurant when my
mom was like you know raising me of this
because I was in a restaurant so and
then coming down to Dallas Texas like
there's just so much opportunity down
here and I got a real sense for the
labor market and kind of did some
research and it's not just about where
the market I'm sure you know anybody
listening in any city right now that has
anything to do with restaurants can
attest to the fact that good helps
harder to find than ever because the
markets oversaturated and it's easier to
get loans to open restaurants and
whatever the case may be
macro economically but I just want to
make a difference so if anybody's
interested me on Twitter at moto G 27
whatever you want to I just want to sort
a bigger conversation around this and
put our content to help people in
restaurants so all right here
well good luck and I'll see you on the
Internet maybe in Texas hurry man well
I'll see you on the road and take it
easy hello hi is this Diana yeah Anna I
was hoping I would get the pronunciation
right this is Tim Ferriss good evening
how are you wow you made it you were the
second person to fill the form out so
you were very very fast on the draw and
awesome thank you for coming my pleasure
what question or questions can i my
question tackles well I have a I have a
couple and I want you to choose do you
wanna you see questions you want a hard
question I want whichever question you
would be most disappointed not to have
asked okay so my biggest interest right
now is what states of higher perception
can we cultivate through training and
what coming to me is sex because sex
seems to be a doorway in some cultures
or some philosophies like I'm thinking
Tantra I'm thinking Taoism I'm thinking
kamasutra and you know so I I've heard
some things and I'm trying to put them
together for example abstaining from sex
like you were talking to jack Kornfield
or withholding orgasm of the training or
multiple partners and other
relationships and let's have a lot of
sex guys as a way of learning how to
deal with your internal stuff so I'm
curious to know what is your experience
if I can assume that you've experimented
with all of this and in what do you
think is that a doorway to higher
perception either of these techniques or
all of them or what what do you think
yeah big question let me try to take a
stab at it so there are many different
opponents to that question
I would say that in general my
experience has been whenever you take an
act or a daily habit let's just say such
as eating and you make previously
automatic or sub conscious decisions
conscious that you can very deliberately
change perception and that that can lead
many interesting places that could take
the form of and I will get to sex but
that could take the form of intermittent
fasting or fasting in which case you
notice how much of your day is
structured around three scheduled meals
whether or not you are hungry and that
brings to you a new appreciation of your
automatic behaviors that may or may not
be justified and secondly gives you a
greater appreciation for in this case
the thing you may abstain from for a
certain period of time which is food and
sex is very similar I do think that and
I don't know if this is physiological or
psychological but I have engaged in a
number of different practices and
schools of training where the accepted
best practices involve abstaining from
sex and furthermore abstaining from
orgasm or ejaculation for a period of
time whether that is two weeks or four
weeks or a longer period of time and
when you remove any compulsive behavior
and I will just go out on a limb and say
I think that masturbation for men in
particular can be a compulsive behavior
and tool for procrastination to put it
mildly women may be also but I think
particularly men
and that when you remove that as an
option and you have for instance a trip
plan where you're going to be engaging
in some type of physical practice or
exposure to psychedelics or whatever it
might be and it is clearly it has been
clearly expressed to you that your your
gains will be 3 X 4 X 5 X greater if you
have stayin from this behavior if that
is the petri dish the the period of
abstinence that can allow you to observe
how you react to that right and
observing the impulses and the
resistance that surfaces I think is
really valuable so I do think that
whether or not there is some type of
physiological basis to the regeneration
a recirculation of Chi for instance
which may or may not be the case right
I'm very very skeptical of a lot of this
new age we lose stuff even though I've
read you know the I believe it's the
multi-orgasmic man Montauk Chia and I've
looked at those exercises and I have
experimented with withholding or
postponing ejaculation in some cases
where you can use say or have a partner
use fingers in the perineum with
pressure to prevent that from happening
yeah mechanically which I don't
I actually think and this is subject
great debate but doesn't strike me as
the healthiest approach is like sticking
a potato in an exhaust pipe or something
it doesn't seem structurally yeah
exactly it also doesn't seem just very
structurally prudent to do that if you
for instance as a male and I mean male
and female physiology of course very
very different when it when it comes to
sex and multiple respects but as a man
certainly learning to develop a
sensitivity to when you're about to
ejaculate and focusing on say breathing
patterns or visualization that let's do
two allows you to extend
the duration of intercourse I think is
tremendously valuable and it also
transcends the bedroom I think it goes
other places right that's my question
actually related to creativity and to
see if there's a correlation between
again I get the discipline and they the
interrupting of the habitual patterns I
understand that but I don't know I have
an experience personally does that
translate into okay then I'm more able
to perceive nature or be more creative
in my writing or be more aware or more
prescient because I'm not giving my
energy into this I yeah I think its
energy I think it's also cognitive load
the the degree to which any given
activity is an interruptive thought and
when you remove something like that for
a period of time it ceases to be static
in the mind and therefore your
signal-to-noise ratio improves and
ostensibly you should be able to in my
experience is that you can you can
operate at a higher level when it comes
to almost all of your other activities
which is why very often when I'm
abstaining from one thing for instance
sex I'll also abstain from alcohol
I will also abstain from caffeine and I
tend to layer those things on top of one
another how how long have you been able
to abstain from say all the stimulants
that distract you from a certain oh yeah
I did it earlier this year for almost
eight weeks which is which is a long
which is a long time for me but I found
it very very worthwhile and it proved to
me also that I could do it and if you
would wonder whether or not you're
addicted some to something you should
try to go without it and you'll you will
potentially suffer physical and
psychological withdrawal symptoms and
your willingness to contend with that
will give you a very accurate read of
how addicted you are to whatever it is
you're abstaining from whether it's a
lot whether it's from addiction it's
more about commitment it's like I've
been exerting with the undulation shower
you know waking up early in the morning
and man is hard to come into it every
single day it's more the discipline
aspect that is exciting to make us is my
I know that if I tackle that then I'll
get a way bigger picture yeah well when
I say addiction I'm not talking about
addiction to nicotine or caffeine
necessarily I'm also talking about
compulsive thought patterns so yeah so
for instance I mean if you're interested
in abstinence of any type or
experimenting with that my
recommendation would actually be if you
really want to see very clear return on
investment quickly I would just Google
21-day no complaint experiment and look
for a blog post that I wrote about a
21-day no complain experiment and this
translates very quickly to multiple
domains when you remove certain patterns
of freezing and not only speaking but
therefore thinking the way that you
relate to the world and the selection
bias you use for seeing the good or
seeing the bad changes very dramatically
so I would recommend taking a look at
that as well yeah no problem so if you
have my dog is whining so I take Molly
out to pee but if you want to get me if
you want to get me a quick question
she's looking straight and gazing into
my eyes as I record this I have to get
her I have to get her outside but what
is if you have one more question that I
can potentially answer quickly I'm happy
I have a quick I don't know if it's a
good question but another another thing
in my mind was I know that you're you're
experimenting a lot with psychedelics
and in how they can they can be used to
treat certain elements or or you know
for healing and I'm just curious as a
person you know I went I went to college
for anthropology and I work right now
with individuals optimizing their
performance through different tools and
I'm thinking when is it a good time to
to encourage somebody to tap into that
and and how can you guide them safely if
if you don't have
a personal experience of it I can't
recommend that you psychedelics you live
in the United States and currently the
classical psychedelics are under
Schedule one which is in the same class
as heroin so if we're considering side
effects you also have to consider the
legal ramifications and potential side
effects what I what I can suggest is
that you investigate something called
holotropic breathwork hol garnet yes it
right so there are got it
psychedelics are one tool in the toolkit
for creating in a non ordinary state of
consciousness that can provide insights
and and realizations and also
reprogramming that can be applied to
different domains really across the
entire spectrum of human experience but
it's not the only tool it just happens
to be a very powerful tool if you want
to strap yourself or strap or encourage
someone to strap themselves to the front
of the Icebreaker
but they're not without risks they're
exceptionally powerful and can be used
irresponsibly and that is why I'm
lobbying very strongly to Shepherd these
compounds specifically MDMA and
psilocybin through phase 3 trials along
with a handful of other people who are
working very very tirelessly on this so
that they can be administered with
medical supervision and trained
therapists I don't think this is that
far away if the stars align in in
certain sense and if anybody wants to
join me in supporting that they should
check out a few organizations use Sona
USO na for psilocybin which is where I'm
spending a lot of my own capital and
attention maps maps org for MDMA which
is effectively there from a funding
perspective for Phase three trials and
then if they want to really come to bat
I'm actually I haven't talked about this
publicly but I'm going to be I am
committing a million dollars of my own
capital
to this over the next several years and
we'll be really directing a lot of my
attention at this field because I cannot
recommend at this point that anyone
pursue psychedelics with the legal
ramifications that exist and also the
difficulty in finding responsible
trained ethical therapists who can
support this work it's just the the risk
benefit ratio is really unappealing for
most folks but what I was going to say
is if anybody wants to come to the table
and believes as I do based on both the
data and experience that they have the
potential to change and even save live
saying treatment resistant depression
and other conditions then then people
can go to Tim blog forward slash science
you know if you really have some capital
that you'd like to bring to bear on this
so I'll say that but at this point I
would I would explore other tools for
[Music]
sorry to interrupt but I was what I was
looking for is where to go for to
support this research because I don't
just want to fall into the hands of
whatever whoever you know what I mean
like like you just said it's hard to
find responsible guidance you know if
you're not in in the yeah in the know
but I know that potential for healing
and I totally get it
that is a work in progress and I totally
support it and yeah you're right the
holotropic breathing is great it just
taps into something but you don't see I
haven't been able to fully fully get the
same result and maybe some matter of
just time and continuous practice yeah
yeah it's okay I'd see keep practicing
and you know also don't forget the slow
and steady reliable methods at your
disposal which would include for
instance meditation sam harris has a
fantastic new app which will be coming
out shortly the waking up app i would
encourage people to take a look at that
there are other options like calm and
headspace but when you start to layer
these things on top of one another you
also very often see effects that are
disproportionate and not additive and
the words you take meditation one-unit
holotropic breathwork one unit and then
say hot and cold works a sauna and ice
baths one unit and you add those up and
it's instead of being three you get a
five or six or seven so I would
encourage you to responsibly experiments
alright Diana I got a run because I have
a list of 20 people to call that I'm
going to try to get through oh go ahead
so much I hope we can at some point
connect again and it was amazing to
share this time in space with you
thank you so much for doing this and
everything you're putting out there it's
amazing no problem my pleasure and hasta
la próxima thanks for taking the time
I've broken my okay bye bye
this is Robin hey Robin this is Tim
Farriss how are you I'm doing so welcome
how are you doing Oh splendid
couldn't be better and I'm excited to be
on the phone with you so I all might I
help we'll see I can fabricate an answer
an attempt to be helpful I can't promise
they'll be of any value but what uh
what's on your mind what can i what can
i potentially help with yeah thank you
delight to be here I've admired for what
10 years now your work and and your
sharing your work with people like us
who sort of follow along in that same
time I've built two somewhat successful
businesses a cafe in San Francisco and
an annual conference but the thing that
you've done so successfully that I
really am just kind of in awe of is
continually hitting success after
success in a way that appeals to the
same target audience so I know you
talked about it's not always being a
success so for our chef for example not
doing quite as well as you wanted or
even I remember what was it rust in iron
a little sure or multiple TV or multiple
TV shows that I've attempted on cable
and elsewhere mm-hmm for sure
and yet you continually spring back so I
look at 4-hour work week through to the
podcast that appeals to people like me
I'm a you know white male living in the
extended area actually just left San
Cisco after 10 years but still in the
extended bay area and 31 and you're able
to create content that appeals to that
same audience and then seemingly grow
that audience over time
I understand starting Miche but
personally and and in terms of I guess
professionally finding the next hit and
then the next hit after that what do you
think other than maybe luck has
contributed to that sort of ongoing
growing success of
gene essentially people like you mm-hmm
cool this is a good this is a good topic
to explore and hopefully my answer isn't
underwhelming I'll try to fuel it with
some more tequila to make it more
interesting let me yeah let me ask a few
clarifying questions if I could uh first
of all I mean you have a shot here she
might have Oh mention it what is your
cafe and what is the conference thank
you yeah I I founded it two years ago
it's called Robin's cafe that seventeen
can shot well in the mission in San
Francisco and then the conference is
about how we work in the 21st century
called responsive conference I bounced
back and forth every year between San
Francisco and New York it's responsive
conference calm happening September 24th
and 25th in New York this next year
there we go
all right cool and what this is this is
all going somewhere but how did you
first come in to contact with me or any
of the the the content that I've put
together whether it be writing audio or
otherwise how did you find your way to
that totally I think I would have come
to it eventually regardless whether
through 4-hour work week or maybe when I
came into contact with your material
originally I think it was time just
after you had published for our body but
like I've come to know
jennice our Klein is a dear friend the
co-founder of she's great you've known a
little bit um Chris Russell the
co-author of team of teams was one of my
speakers so like I've been peripheral to
your work may be very peripheral but
sort of circling around for a lot of
years I think the first thing of yours I
saw that really hooked me was early on
in the shopify competitions you had a
little video about building online
businesses and at the time I was
dabbling with Shopify trying to sell
digital content for parents of kids with
autism which was a career of about five
years that I had there and and something
about your authenticity via video that
then led me to your first TED talk that
then funnily enough led me for our work
week and I've really been following
along
very cool appreciate the the context
alright so let me try to tackle this and
[Music]
I'll edge into it a few different ways
so the first the first thing I would say
as a caveat is that even if I make a
very overt attempt to talk about my
failures and missteps and so on the
ratio of successes to failures that make
their way on to the internet or my
podcast or into the books still presents
a very skewed misperception that I
succeed a disproportionate amount of the
time and what that does not mean however
that I am continually failing and then
just highlighting the one or two
successes what it means I think if I'm
trying to look at it as an observer is
that number one I increase the
likelihood of success by doing one thing
very reliably I'm not even going to say
well but one thing very reliably and
that is try to support and create
products or chapters that scratch an
itch I have okay so it's a very
simplistic model it doesn't always work
but I assume that if something really
grabs my attention that it will grab the
attention of at least 10,000 other
people on the planet who speak English
and that that you start really narrow
and for me I stick with what I know and
what I know is my daily experience of
the things I want the daily experience
of the things that bother me the daily
experience of things that are a huge
pain in my ass
the simple path I have found to be most
reliable
for reaching 10,000,000 people reaching
a hundred million people is starting
with the thing that you [ __ ] know the
best and that is your daily experience
of pain or desire for pleasure or
problems or solutions and sharing that
and really not [ __ ] yourself by
overthinking it and getting to
sophisticated really focus on what you
know as an individual and identify the
primary pain points and if you can find
solutions to those for yourself
generally speaking that will really
transcend any type of category that you
fit neatly into and will affect a lot of
people that's been my experience so
that's a very I can't believe how
[ __ ] long that was oh my god so
hopefully yeah hopefully that's helpful
in some capacity but the reason that
I've had the success I've had in say
investing is because I I have set very
strict rules which I sometimes violate
to my detriment but for the most part
I've stuck with very very simple rules
for investing in things that fix a
personal problem that I am willing to
pay money to fix right and that excludes
a lot of companies that have done
spectacularly well that I have missed
and it doesn't matter because you've
it's not about how many you miss it's
about how many you actually get right
and that's true for entrepreneurship as
it is for investing and I've just tried
very very hard not to outsmart myself
and it makes me think of a quote from
Charlie Munger who's the right hand
investing partner Warren Buffett and it
is something along the lines of you know
it's incredible how far you can go by
trying to not be consistently stupid so
you're not trying to outsmart everyone
you're just trying not to be
consistently stupid and what I would put
into the consistently stupid category is
is really trying to project and
hypothesize too much when it comes to
entrepreneurship or investing like focus
on what's right in front of
you and it can take you really far so
apologize for how long that took but
this is something that I feel very
strongly about because the results are
so clear to me when people pay attention
to it awesome so there you have it yeah
nice I'm reminded of what I think it was
Warren Buffett who told you at
shareholder meeting like if you have
money to invest invest in the stock
market and get back to work
yeah invested in an S&P 500 and get back
to work like the most disappointing
answer from a hero ever but in
retrospect it made a lot of sense yeah
yeah hey if this isn't your game yeah if
this isn't your stock picking game then
you shouldn't play so you get your face
ripped off so it's like put your money
in the S&P 500 get back to work yeah and
then psychographic so regardless of what
a person looks like or sounds like or
where they live the focus on specific
problems that I as an individual have
and and who do I want to help those
people like me to come whether they look
like me or not doing that consistently
and showing up again and again and
getting back to work
yeah totally let me ask let me add a few
things also because I don't want this to
seem too high concept 30,000 feet and
that is I avoid a lot of big failures by
failing quickly with a lot of low cost
tests and that means for instance rust
and iron you mentioned which is this it
and who knows maybe it'll be resurrected
but it didn't get nearly the kind of
attention that I would have hoped given
how excited I was about it right so some
of these don't work and for those who
don't know this was a very short video
series I put up a few of them on YouTube
so youtube-dot-com forward-slash Tim
Ferriss which were tours of gems
think so think cribs for Jim's write
endlessly fascinating to me turns out
most of the world doesn't give a single
[ __ ] about it
and I did a few of these and they were
you know I filmed them on actually one
of them was just with an iPhone with
Kelly Starrett and then a handful of
others with Mark Bell and so on were
with much nicer cameras but those
experiments cost a few hundred dollars
apiece maybe a little bit more and I
decided for myself what the max
allowable cost was so how much am I
willing to sink into this to arrive at a
decision as to whether to continue or
not it was like okay few thousand bucks
I'm willing to put that in and depending
on where you are in your entrepreneurial
journey that might be 80 bucks it might
be zero dollars it might be if you're if
you have much more to play with in terms
of capital it might be a million dollars
but in this case I was like you know
what this isn't a revenue driver it's
really just for [ __ ] shits and
giggles to see if people respond to it
well or not I'm gonna put in a few
thousand bucks over a period of two
months and see what happens and what
happened was [ __ ] crickets and I was
like okay well we're not gonna do any
more of those unless I receive some type
of information that directly and
powerfully in some meaningful way
contradicts this like f+ grade that I
just got on this experiment so so if you
don't mind going into the specifics how
do you determine like I just launched a
tiny little podcast called Xander strong
my last name being van der and again it
was crickets but like I know I could ask
everyone I know to leave a review on
iTunes for that project right if you
direct your audience again and again
towards a couple of videos those videos
that will explode if you wanted to get
sponsorship I think you probably could
so how do you determine crickets and
that your audience your psychographic
was not interested in rust and iron yeah
so there's all right so if we're looking
at just to digress but not really
digress into a related topic if you look
at investment pitches from startups as a
venture capitalists or angel investor
you will surprise surprise see the same
graph and a lot of them wow it looks
like a hockey stick up into the right
fantastic
and the question that any investor
should ask among others is what
percentage of this growth is represented
through organic growth and what
percentage of this growth is represented
through paid acquisition because
founders being incentivized as they are
will very often go into the dark arts
and take some of their pre-existing
funding or whatever money they might
have through cash flow or other means
and invest it in artificially boosting
the numbers right
and you can do this in an attempt to
trick yourself as well and I think it's
Richard formate Richard Fineman who said
physicist anyone who wants to read a
fantastic book should read surely I
think surely you're joking mr. Fineman
one of my favorites in any case he said
you know rule number and I'm
paraphrasing all these but rule number
one is you must not fool yourself and
you are the easiest person to fool so I
really try to a focus on real metrics
versus vanity metrics and I would put in
vanity metrics almost every [ __ ]
buzzword is your that you can imagine
like engagement and I think it just does
not [ __ ] matter for the most part I
will look at and I cannot say this
applies to everyone I can tell you how I
will evaluate these things okay
so I'll look at the I'll look at the and
it's partially to determine whether
something is dead on arrival with no
hope of revival or if I'm performing an
experiment and it's 10% off and if I
tweak that 10% it could explode which is
sometimes the case so if we look at rust
and iron specifically I'm not just
looking at the view count I'm looking at
the comments and this is a subjective
not even gonna say science art but it's
a bit of a gestalt pattern-matching type
of process that I'll go through where I
will look for intensity of feedback so
if I look at the 30 I love it people who
hate it right I will look at the 30 and
I'll primarily look at the people who
love it because it doesn't matter how
many people don't get it
it matters how many people do get it
right you can have 90 percent of the
people in a given City hate your [ __ ]
business more than anything on the
planet but if 10 percent of San
Francisco loves your cafe
you are [ __ ] set you know I mean like
you are set it doesn't matter
like you you are going to have a super
mega homerun on your hands it doesn't
matter how many people don't get it it
matters how many people do get it so
I'll pay attention to the positive
feedback and if the positive feedback is
along the lines of oh my god
this would be the best thing I've ever
seen in my life I really loved a B and C
but it'd be great to have this and this
if I see that type of feedback over and
over again I will test again if I and
this is also related to my editing
process for books when I edit books I
will ask people which for instance and
these are almost always friends of mine
who are writers that I asked to do this
although lawyers are very good at
editing because they can find sloppy
thinking in words that shouldn't be
there or ambiguous wording and thinking
I will ask them to identify the 10% they
would absolutely keep if I had to cut
everything else and the 10% they would
cut no matter what or the 10% they would
cut if they had to write and if so it
takes only one person to love something
more than the other 90% for me to keep
it in the book but it takes more of a
consensus for me to cut something does
that make sense if somebody absolutely
loves something even if nobody else
mentions it it stays in because my
assumption is there at least 10,000 more
people who care about that and I don't
want to live in the comfortable middle
ground which is the gray of I like this
because that is where you die and if you
make something you think everyone will
like you're gonna make something no one
will love and I try very hard then to
straddle that and not deliberately
create things that people will hate but
in the process of
selecting for things that people love
the side effect will be the head in this
pendulum of public opinion you will have
people who hate it almost by definition
so that is how I would look at something
like rust and iron and I didn't have a
overwhelmingly strong response even from
a minority they they did not offer and
this is an indicator of liking something
in feeling I invested I did not get a
lot of quality constructive feedback
in other words hey this car is fantastic
it's a Ferrari but the front suspension
is [ __ ] if you fix that it would be a
homerun I didn't get that type of
feedback and that's part of the reason
why I shelved it it's not dead forever
but it might be whereas in the podcast
case and here's here's another layer
that I would add to it it's not just
what other people think in other words
with the podcast I was willing to slog
through some [ __ ] awful first
episodes and they weren't all terrible
but some of them were let's be honest I
mean I've done 300 now hopefully it's
better but if some of the some of the
original episodes are really rough and I
slogged through it why because I was
developing additional skill sets the
ability to ask questions right I was
developing additional skill sets the
ability to let silence do the work the
ability to ask follow-up questions which
default follow-up questions yield a lot
of fruit such as how did that make you
feel what did you learn from that
how have you implemented that later etc
as well as developing deeper
relationships with people I knew as well
as people I didn't know as well
acquaintances or even strangers if you
want to have a really funny /
frustrating experience you can listen to
my first ever podcast interview with a
stranger someone I'd never spoken to
before that point in time we just IDI
Catmull the president of Pixar I was
really really nervous and I want mm-hmm
mmm-hmm like a thousand [ __ ] times
that drove people nuts anyway III was I
was developing skills and relationships
or deep in relationships that would
transcend that given project
so I cared less about where I waited
less weighed maybe weighted weighed less
the public opinion of those early
episodes does that make sense yeah
because unlike say rust and iron where I
was producing new content but not really
developing new skills there was a value
to the practice of the podcast in and of
itself and that is true of a lot of what
I do I really try to select whenever
possible for what will help me to
develop skills and relationships that
will trin transcend that project in part
because I can really effectively ignore
the early feedback and I don't ignore it
but I it is 10% of my consideration yeah
you're not dependent on the early
feedback to determine the success of the
project right and that's another mmm
litmus test perhaps or another set of
criteria that I've used consistently to
increase the odds of each subsequent
project success but it's it's in some
ways laughably simplistic and it's
really hard to keep something simplistic
it's a intellectually difficult to keep
something simplistic because you want to
demonstrate to yourself that you're so
[ __ ] smart you start to add in
additional criteria and use spreadsheets
and all this stuff and it's not to say
that that stuff isn't warranted but if
you meet with a founder and you're like
[ __ ] this guy gives me the
heebie-jeebies
doesn't matter how good your goddamn
spreadsheet is you should listen to that
very primitive intuition it's probably
telling you something that over millions
of years of evolution is more
sophisticated than whatever you put into
Excel that afternoon right I've tried to
really really really really revert to
the simple and
you want to give it a nicer name the
elegant then the sophisticated or
complex which is not to say there isn't
a place for the complex and the
sophisticated if you're doing if you're
a gross stage or late stage private
equity investor and you're thinking
about taking over a company and
replacing the management and improving
operational efficiencies well you better
really know your numbers but that's not
the game that I play that is not my
power zone and I will get annihilated if
I try to compete against people who are
good in those space it's just not my
sandbox so for me I really try to target
areas where I have a really really basic
advantage and that is that I can stick
to complete I can stick to simplicity
rather and a real pared down set of
criteria when other people are tempted
to go to complexity and succumb to
complexity and I don't have many
advantages none of us I really want to
go as far as to say none of us have that
many [ __ ] advantages so figure out
what is easy for you that is hard for a
lot of your friends and start there and
then look at your personal pains look at
your personal desires and use that as a
starting point if you're trying to
create content or products that you hope
will ultimately impact billions of
people and guess what a lot of these
products like duolingo right I was in
there first as best I can recall their
first round of financing at the time
because it was the first language
learning software that made sense to me
that solved a lot of pain points for me
personally as a language learning
student and now as best I know it is the
most widely used free language learning
software on the planet right hundred
million plus users but it didn't start
by thinking about what those hundred
million people needed it started with
asking myself does this or does this not
scratch the itch solve the pain that I
experienced my
so I hope that helps but that's that's
partially how I think about this kind of
thing thank you no I really appreciate
your time and taking the time sure yeah
hopefully that wasn't too drunk cool
well good luck with everything and if I
ever make my way back to the Bay Area I
won't check out your cafe hey guys this
is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun for the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is sponsored by Sotheby's
and Safa B's wine which offers a
selection of the world's best wines for
every palate and occasion many of you
know I do like my wine I do love wine
must be the Malbec from Argentina when I
was down there or maybe it's the
Zinfandel from California but I like it
all I like lots and lots of wine
Sotheby's as many of you may know is a
global auctioneer they auction off many
many many different types of things
they're also a retailer of fine wine
with locations in New York London and
Hong Kong they recently created an
online store where you can buy wine
directly you might think well that's for
millionaires and billionaires I don't
auction houses but the wines that they
sell range from $14 per bottle all the
way up to 25,000 let's say Safa B's
allows you to sort by region great
producer or even search for a particular
bottle or by your budget which is
probably where I would go if you're
gifting wine South the bass suggests
champagne red Bordeaux burgundy or
Californian wines and if you want my
opinion I would say you know trying
Zinfandel if you haven't tried the
Zinfandel from California but in a case
just one restriction at this time south
of these can only ship to New York
California DC New Hampshire and Idaho so
I'll say that one more time now put it a
different way if you are in or shipping
to New York California DC New Hampshire
or Idaho check it out because that's
where the wine can currently be shipped
so visit Sotheby's wine.com ves s o th e
b ys south of e's wine.com
and use the promo code Tim T I am to get
10% off of your first order again that's
south of e's wine.com and use promo code
Tim for 10% off y'all did this is why
check it out
this episode is brought to you by
peloton and I'd heard about peloton over
and over again but I ended up getting a
peloton bike in the whole system after I
saw my buddy Kevin Rose I've known him
forever
some of you know and he showed up at my
gate at my house a while back and he
looked fantastic hey I asked him as a
dude you look great what the hell have
you been up to he's always doing a weird
diet or another but it only lasts like a
week of two so he always regresses to
the mean after like 75 beers and he said
I've been doing peloton five days a week
now that caught my attention cuz Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know I love you Kevin but it really
piqued my curiosity ended up getting a
system and it's become an integral part
of my week I love it and I really didn't
expect to love it at all because I find
cycling really boring usually but
peloton is an indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right into
your home
you know if worried about fitting
classes in your schedule and making it
to a studio with some type of commute
etc new classes are added every day and
this includes options led by elite New
York City instructors in your own living
room
you can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors
or find your own favorite class on
demand and in fact Kevin and I rarely do
live classes and you can compete with
your friends which is also fun Kevin I'm
coming after you but we usually just use
classes on demand I really like Matt
Wilbur's and his eye on high intensity
training sessions that are shorter like
20 minutes and I think Kevin's favorite
is Alex and everyone seems to have their
favorite instructor or you can select by
music duration and so on each peloton
bike includes a 22 inch HD touchscreen
performance tracking metrics I think
that along with the real-time
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before
it's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention the belt drive is quiet
and it's smaller than you would expect
so it can fit in a living room or an
office I actually have it in a large
closet believe it or not and it fits
with no problem so peloton is offering
all of you guys listeners of the Tim
Ferriss show a special offer and it is
actually special visit one peloton
that's o-n-e PE l OT on1 peloton comm
and enter the code Tim all caps TI m at
checkout to receive $100 off accessories
with your peloton bike purchase now you
might say man accessories wait I don't
need fancy towels or whatever other
supplemental bits and pieces no the
shoes you need you need the clip in
shoes and those are in the accessory
category so there's $100 off is a very
legit hundred dollars off so if you want
to get in your workouts if you want a
convenient and really entertaining way
to do high-intensity interval training
or anything else or you just want to get
a fantastic gift for someone
check out peloton one peloton calm and
enter the code of Tim
again that's oh and EPE l o t-- o-- n
dot-com and enter the coat in a check
out to receive $100 off any accessories
including the shoes that you will want
to get check it out
one peloton comm code Tim
you
you